hey what's up guys my name is Anna
welcome to episode 28 a pretty game
programming in Java okay so the deal was
last time we had this little contraption
thing here a little fake a mock-up
button I guess and a bunch of other
stuff and and today's episode I actually
I actually um decided you know if this
is probably gonna be a pretty
complicated at episode so I thought you
know it's gonna take me a while to
figure out so why don't have some fun
and live streaming so I did I actually
live streamed myself making this on
Thursday I think it was I think it was
Thursday I'm not sure I remember but I
think I did it on Thursday so um I
actually I think I did put put up a
video on YouTube thing that I would be
live-streaming but the point is um with
a lot of fun of the stream and and make
sure you follow me on Twitter
twitter.com for scishow no link is on
the screen and in the description and
that way you'll never miss a live stream
and yeah so for those of you guys who
actually watch the stream you probably
already know how to do this because um
well yeah because I did live but uh the
point is there's actually a lot of code
you know I I probably spend about two
hours on that stream just because
obviously I had to figure out the whole
thing and um and also because I tried a
few different ways of doing it and
basically it was like trial and error
and I died and I thought that you know
that there's there's just so many ways
that I want to handle this and I'm not
sure I don't want to do it in such a way
that will just confuse you guys and make
it really complicated and make it
unnecessarily complicated but you know I
even went from something as having
multiple threads and that's probably
probably what we'll do we'll probably
run multiple threads we'll have a thread
for the menu for this launcher this
launcher will of a thread for this
launcher and we'll also have a thread
for arm it's actually game itself but
what we're gonna do this week because I
had to sort of break it down into two
episodes because it was just so much
like I can't do an hour and a half
episode and then expect you guys to a
watch it and be to actually take
something out of it so I want to sort of
break this down and rather than rather
than just do like basically the like the
two hundred lines of code that we
probably have to write for this probably
even more
mm I I'm actually gonna really go into
the depth here and see how well I can
explain the stuff you alright so first
thing you need to realize is this stuff
will come in handy where whenever you
know if you're making an application and
you want to have custom buttons and
basically want to customize your
application then this will come in handy
if you're making the game and you wanna
make a graphical user interface in an
actual game this will come in handy
there's just this this stuff is so
useful I know that a lot of people want
me to get back to the game and I will
like collision detection actual levels
you know all that stuff maybe like a sky
instead of the same - on the top and
bottom all that stuff that is coming in
the future guys don't worry I will do
that and I'll probably do that as soon
as I wrap up this launcher so if you're
if you're sort of looking for that then
uh then ah don't worry that will come
but at the moment of the want to finish
this up so let's just take a look at
basically the analysis stage of our
problem-solving methodology methodology
whatever what what we need to do at the
moment is make four buttons right if you
actually I'm gonna open steam again so
we can use our Skyrim launcher as as
reference but uh one of the things we
need to do is make four buttons and the
other thing we need to do is actually um
is actually make this movable so if we
can if we click and drag this there's
actually no way to move this window and
a that's really not really nice for
debugging because um oh hang on what was
that about Magic the Gathering damn and
how do you see that thing again
damnit the song about magic gathering
and I like that game um anyway it's like
a trading card game anyway um you know
this so if we open this game once you
can see that we can move it anywhere we
want and that's all cool and but we
can't move this at all so we didn't fix
that we do that then we've also got a
bunch of buttons here they actually
change as we overlaid them and I
actually don't like how the bottom
senses are all the way here we're
probably not going to do this probably
gonna make it if you actually are
somewhere on the text it will highlight
and you can see that there's like an
arrow type thing that appears next to it
will also do that so I should be fun
so we'll do play options help and exit
that's the four buttons that will do so
let's jump into this first thing I want
to do is actually do those buttons so ah
should I maybe I should make this move
first yeah let's let's make this whole
thing move first because it's annoying
me how when I'm when I want to debug and
I've only got one screen I can't
actually even if I've got two strings I
can't move it over to the next screen so
that's sort of annoying and it's
actually really is easy to do now the
first thing you'll notice is if we're
going to launch up we've got this set
location relative to know which means it
is said it basically says that it's the
middle of our screen of your primary
monitor if you've got to and that's all
cool but the thing is we want to sort of
we want to update that position all the
time
and so the thing is if we if we go ahead
and set location he called us to a
specific point like 2020 for example so
that'll be 20 let's actually make it 20
by 200 so I'll be 20 here and 200 down
so it should be about here or something
I don't know I'm probably about here
actually got here you can say that it
actually they're gay it overrides the
set location so in other words what we
sort of want to do is we want to say all
right well let's let's do that to start
off with so there's sort of in the
center but then when we click and drag
on the window let's adjust this now the
thing is if you actually notice this if
we go onto here
and let's not set this to 2,200 let's
set this to like 1200 if we have the
launcher over here and we want to update
this - like say let's bring it down to
500 - 500 we hit control s and nothing
happens it doesn't auto update and you
guys might be like hey why doesn't auto
update is that eclipses problem no it's
completely not Eclipse its problem it's
a problem that this code only happens
once this code does not continue it's
not in a loop right the thing is we can
adjust stuff like rendering you know why
because our render menu method which
controls the rendering for example or
even our render method which controls
the game is inside the run method but
but more importantly it's inside the
while running loop which means that this
code is being continually reran right so
it it updates because this stuff is just
it's continually running it's going it's
doing this in chronological order when
it gets to the end of this when it gets
to this bracket it goes back sorry this
bracket it goes back no I'm still wrong
yeah what's this bracket once it reaches
this bracket it goes back up to the top
and starts doing it again and it does
that as many times per second as it
possibly can so that's how it works if
we adjust something in the while loop
then it will update so the logical thing
that I hope you guys will pick up here
is when I want to basically change
dynamically change the position of the
thing I need this set location thing
there's some yeah this this set location
thing to be in some kind of loop so
let's do that right now let's cut it
let's make a new method we'll make it
public public void public void update
frame we'll call it update frame because
I'm just so that we can say that
anything in here will be continually
updated and then here we'll paste our
set location 500 at five hundred to two
hundred five hundred by two hundred so
five hundred expert ordered why now that
works and now let's go to our display
and make sure that we are where your
launcher
launcher equals new launcher and it's
gonna ask us for this crap hmm this is
mine all right doesn't matter okay I
might get rid of those parameters later
cuz they're annoying but um best what
we're doing is we're we're making an
object out of launchers so that we can
then later into our run method right
onto right up here we can actually we
only need a request focus once doesn't
move that up into the run method rather
than the wild running hope let's just go
ahead and type launcher dot update frame
now to demonstrate this update frame now
to demonstrate the best thing is if I
put let's just comment what let's just
comment this card out for a second if I
put system dot out dot print line and I
put something like updating then you can
see that once we run it it's gonna crash
why did it crash a nullpointerexception
what small
we've suddenly got a
nullpointerexception Wow that is
actually remarkable so what'd you do
with that tick method game dog tick
so maybe game equals know what that is
well if debug this for a second
wow that is I'm fairly sure that we
didn't modify any of that code though
huh
maybe I accidentally deleted a line I'm
not sure that's peculiar okay let's just
let's see if that had anything to do
with that
let's go into launch our pet frame let's
just come with that out and see if it
runs no it doesn't so it had nothing to
do with us it had something to do with
somehow this managed to hold null how do
we do that did I accidentally delete a
lot of code you guys in your and your
video that you're watching right now
you'll just be able to go back in time
and see what I did what I can't I can't
just take controls that a few times and
see what I did
I moved the request focus oh now it's
gone what
oh hang on I think I know what I did
wrong I am yeah
all right hell's my bad probably
something to do with the fact that I did
launch a launcher because new launcher
and I actually said this as a thing
let's see if that actually makes a crash
yep
all right cool so we haven't initialized
it so if I put a new display then it's
okay nevermind let's go to launcher and
let's just disable this better make this
um well have a kind of dude or okay yeah
this is getting annoying isn't it
I hope you guys can say what the problem
is alright
that's quite weird
all right I think that okay I think that
will scrap that from now and will
actually mmm yeah okay
first thing we'll do is let's just do
what I wanted to do first which was to
actually um you know yeah we'll do that
alright so the thing that I want to do
right now let's just make sure that
launched a plan that's runnable and
let's add that run clause in here and
it's out of it to the very bottom so
basically what we're doing now is we're
saying that our launcher is gonna be
basically a separate program from our
from our thing it's going to be
completely separate program from our
actual arm what do you call it from our
game which is what we wanted to sort of
do it because it's completely separate
so let's especially make a while running
thing again so we'll make a boolean
called running and we'll set it equal to
false all right and then also make a
start menu method which will just
basically say you thread this dot start
so we'll start a thread enniaa and and
we'll give the thread of name we'll call
it menu and and we want to we don't
really need to stop it actually I kind
of do actually okay let's do it for my
let's just stop menu and we'll go thread
dot join and I will actually cut half
this card thread dot start a thread
equals you thread and we'll make a
thread thread up here alright and we'll
try to catch this nope
try and catch we actually haven't used
the throws thing like the throws
exception thing we might we might use
that in the future because I'm aware
that a few of you guys probably don't
know what that means but basically video
is want to try and catch whatever you
can whatever you want to sometimes it's
more convenient to throw stuff so if
you've got a lot of code here that you
want to just have it throw exceptions
and yeah you can do that but it's better
to try cash because you'll you'll if you
if you add a throws right if you add a
throws exception thing you will need to
try and cash somewhere okay you will
need to try and catch somewhere anyway
so instead of being like yeah I'll try
and cash it later we can try and catch
it now okay so that should that should
be fine and what we need to do is we
need to run the start menu method and
also when we go on to display whoops
we'll go on to the start method here
here it is um then we can actually name
this game method so this is our game
method so that when we actually debug
and we go and here we can say that our
game thread is running and we can see
that our menu thread isn't actually
running at the moment so that's kind of
weird hang on let's just as our launcher
all right I should have actually started
it we had all right well we need to set
hunting equal to true as well and then
if we put something here so like system
dot out dot print line running then it
should continually print that line if
we've done everything correctly and we
have all right cool so now we can
actually put our update frame method
into here and if we run this you can see
that you know semicolon
you can see that we are updating all
right so if we go into um if we go into
uh into our thing here and actually get
rid of this code and uncomment the set
location thing you'll see that if I set
the location of this thing and I adjust
it to like a thousand hit control s and
lucky to auto updates why because we're
continually because it's in the while
loop we're continually updating this
update frag yet control D just eats up
lines I don't know why it's kind of
stupid anyway I guess could be useful in
some senses but to me really not because
I just I can just you know shift it up
our Italy whole lines affair don't need
to UM yes you'll see that and you can
change that to whatever you like so now
that we've got this newfound wisdom type
thing we can actually go ahead and play
around with this but we can also simply
go ahead and say that when we move the
mouse now let's list let's do that whole
deal okay so the deal is the deal is
that our we've already got an input
handle class right
we called it input Handler I believe
here it is so we've already got this
whole thing now so we don't have to add
and it would handle it to this method we
just need to use the already existed
existent input handler class so we'll
need a few things
all right well then it actually declare
a few great values here the first thing
is mouse tracked so we've got the mouse
X&Y location now it's simply the X&Y
location of the screen and what we need
is let's just type public static int not
public public static int Mouse D
now I'll call that drag X and for you
guys who a graphics program is and game
developers you'll note D X and D twice
as for other stuff but for now we'll
just bear with me D says the drag okay
if you don't believe me you can just go
D equals drag just guess you could
forget or something so the days are drag
and the other thing we need to do is we
need to sort of get the location when we
press it so we'll go public static int
Mouse P X so pressed X I'm making these
up as I go along by the way so if you've
got a better name you can just go
mousepressed or whatever X but uh DX is
for drag and so this is our suppress
coordinates okay so let's go down into
Mouse dragged and let's just simply hit
Mouse D X equals e dot get X and mouse d
y equals e dot get Y and by the way it's
Easter today so happy Easter to all of
you guys I was gonna say yes this is
like the Easter special quote-unquote
episode of I'm pretty unfair me Joe not
really but there's nothing really
special about this episode but yeah but
happy Easter to all of you guys to
Christians out there you know happy
Jesus rising from the cross type deal
day and yeah so let's let's get on with
this alright so we've done this and we
also need to do that Mouse pressed thing
so when mouse is pressed we need to set
Mouse P X equal to e dot get X and mouse
P y equals they don't get Y so the
reason we're doing arm for 20 minutes
the reason we're doing this a is because
obviously Mouse event is called a sure I
don't need to explain this and I don't
know why we've got these overrides let's
get rid of these they don't actually do
anything is kind of like comments by the
way
they kind of let us know that we're
overriding the methods of our
implementations obviously all right cool
okay so let's go back into our launcher
and what we can also do is say let's
also print out the mouse coordinates on
the screen and see if that actually even
works because let's do that so what we
want to sort of print out is our
x-coordinate on the screen so x plus
input Handler dot mouse X as well as our
Y and our input Handler mouse y mousey
and then you can see that but judging by
this obviously it's working and let's
actually get rid of this set size that
location thing and you can see how
that's working how this is 0 0 pretty
much and this is part of our frame yeah
800 by 480 lat
a mouse listener yeah or Mouse most
emotional listeners at least and yes
let's get let's get into um actually
actually doing this so this there is
some basic math behind this I'm not
gonna explain in great detail but a good
thing that we can actually use is um we
need to sort of get the location of our
frame right now there's actually this
few ways of doing this let's first of
all let's get rid of this entire thing
because we're gonna start from the
update frame thing again we want to only
only move the frame if we detect that
it's getting dragged now how do we get
dragged pretty easily if we go into
Mouse pressed then drag nickles true
right because we're pressing the mouse
and we're holding it down but if we
release the mouse drag diggle's false
all right so now let's make a boolean up
here
a public static bullying called dragged
and let's set that equal to false by
default so by default we're obviously
not dragging anything and I'll come in
here and we'll say that if input handler
dot dragged equals true right and you
can actually do equals true but you
don't need to or equals false you guys
know that if it equals true then you
just put that if you want to take all
false then you hit an exclamation mark
at the front so if if we are dragging
then let's set up two variables the X
the current we want to get the current
coordinates of the actual frame so X is
gonna equal get X I think that yeah and
Y is gonna equal get Y and again we are
extending jframe so it would be like J
frame frame equals new jframe frame
don't get why but we're not actually
when I'm making an object out of it so
it's just get X and get what and what we
want to do here is we want to set the
location frame dot set location same
thing as we did before to our X variable
plus plus our mouse DX minus our our
mouse px all right and then same thing
for y so y plus input handler dot mouse
dy minus input Handler dot mouse whoops
non capitals Mouse P Y all right and
again I've just gone frame this location
it's just that location right so it's
very very simple
yeah that's it so let's check out and
see if this works
and it did not work it did not work
all right so let's just sort of recover
and see what we did wrong
what
actually happen there so I just clicked
on it and then it's suddenly disappeared
the thing is is that why are we adding
displaying twice first of all what
that's weird thing is mouse motion
listener why's we're adding it in anyway
the thing is it's completely stopped
working you know and I'm not sure why
it's like this it's I don't know input
handler dot dragged never seems to equal
true ever if we press the mouse less
that dragged equal to true you press the
mouse dragged doesn't equal true why
I'm not working some other stuff you
know then let's add a key listener as
well and let's add a focus listen up
actually maybe that's a fact I'm not
sure not when we run this we missing
focus
I think it might be okay let's let's go
into our random and render menu method
and cut that from here because I don't
want anything to have to do with display
at all that's all I want this run
independently let's go ahead and pass it
into here and everything is fine and
we'll put this random menu method into
our thing here and then we won't have to
add display anymore there we go
damn what was that all about all right
well back I didn't I'm not gonna fall
for the roll down but you can see that's
okay if anyone knows why that was
happening like in a legit concise format
please post a comment below because I
have no idea why that happened it
shouldn't have happened and it did okay
so our drag thing works now it's gone to
input Handler and disable mouse press
drag thing and let's see if that works
okay it sort of does you can see that
we're sort of moving it and it's it is
working but for some reason keeps
flickering so that's weird and it's
probably something to do with yeah we're
just absolutely no actually it works now
so if we drag it will set the location
to that plus DX minus px and py + Mouse
dy py
why should worked
oh the other thing we'll be able to drag
it with all of our Mouse pointers why is
this it do that
that's weight as if there's two but
there's not two it's just that it's sort
of it's flickering between does it
matter where is it
maybe that's no it doesn't matter where
I present it still does it huh
this is fun diagnosing is not gonna be a
long episode long episode so when we
press the mouse we get the x and y and
we put that the PX and py that's product
and then
when we drag it wheel so you got the X&Y
correctly
and it doesn't work oh I'm getting bored
of this and sick of this and I'm not
sure wise doing this all right I need
some dubstep music too bad I can't
actually do that because of copyright
issues maybe it's a screen recorder no
shouldn't be shouldn't have been if you
do with that oh we should be framed Oh
cut location are you kidding me oh this
sucks
alright so it works now it works now so
keep in mind that if you don't have read
on the lines on the occurred then you're
not right alright because canvas also
has a method called get location and
jframe also has a method as a method
called get location and they're
completely different so now we've got a
working functional thing which we can
move anywhere we want at 43 minutes so
that's the deal now I know you guys are
gonna hate me now because this took a
while but we're actually we're not done
yet
this probably this episode's gonna be
over like over an hour longer than him
you know phone upload tonight but I'll
try nonetheless um let's start on those
buttons now so we want what what we sort
of want to do right now is you're a
bunch of buttons on the screen that we
can actually interact with as we can in
the scarran warship so let's do that
right now we'll make an exit button
we'll make a play button we'll make a
options button and options button and
we'll make a help button so first thing
I want to do and I'm gonna open
Photoshop again another Photoshop
tutorial for you guys but um but not
really not so much tutorials is just
you guys watching me alright so hope you
guys are understanding everything so far
we'll go file and we'll go open we're
new and let's just make it like 80 by
like 30 same thing like a good size
and make sure the background is
transparent all right so you've got no
background let's just have play and I'm
just going to use the century font
because it's cool and I'm just gonna go
out bold and stuff and I color my
insights like a not like a light gray
but maybe like it just below 50% gray so
we're not gonna go 50 but they go like
40 or something : or maybe even like 35
make you want to make it dark but the
thing is you want to still make it
readable because remember this is quite
dark so don't make it too dark
I'll make it 38 hit okay and we'll just
right click blending options and I'm
gonna add like some basic stuff like a
drop shadow if you check out the scar
and washer then you'll see that they've
sort of got like a little drop shadow
going on so I'm not sure if you can see
that you can't see that I'm in the
recording because you can barely see it
in real life but we might make the
distance like two pixels maybe maybe two
and the size maybe like three or
something so it's more defined so the
larger the size the more sort of you can
see how it guess out this sort of makes
it like a one pixel one makes it really
sort of defined so you can see that if
we go zero then it's just basically a
copy and if we get that out then you
can't even see it anymore
so we'll make it about two maybe and
we'll make the distance like what free
to make the distance to as well Alex
nice um and we might turn the opacity
down slightly so it's not that uh that's
thing and outer glow
we might actually make like a a bluish
type really subtle bluish type thing so
ten the opacity way down and maybe not
blue simply
why doesn't and that's what just getting
all read maybe weren't having a let's
just keep this pretty simple well Kate
will bust in a little small inner glow
just so we can make it a little bit
cooler and we might trick it out a bit
alright so that's first screw the inner
glow um that'll be enough oh crap I hit
cancel damn it ok I'm back to square one
drop shadow at true distance too and we
won't have any kind of spray let's
Prettyman do oh well no no spread hit
okay so we've got that let's file save
as and let's find a appropriate I can
just save it so Eclipse workspace to my
front test up on my front test my front
resources and I'm gonna make a new
folder called menu and I'm gonna also
make a folder called Ridge and a ridge
is gonna be where I save all of the
Photoshop files so in case I want to
edit this in the future I don't want to
have to edit it you can't really edit a
JPEG anymore but you can edit a
Photoshop file so we'll save this as
button underscore play and we'll save it
and then also less control shift s and
save it let's get out and save it as a
PNG in our menu directory as button
we'll play safe Y for it wait for it
come on there it is okay not into this
none and then we'll do the exact same
thing but we'll change the color from
that and from 6-1 6-1 6-1 to like a much
brighter type thing so it's like in
Skyrim you'll see that when we hit the
mouse it makes it kind of makes it white
pretty much we're not gonna make it out
white it's gonna make it like that kind
of gray it okay ctrl shift s and
actually let's just have it just play
underscore on there's like this is when
the buttons on and let's get over to our
thing and we will rename will quickly
rename button play to play off this is
the off button and we'll do the same
thing for here as well okay cool and
that's so let's open the play off button
again and we'll change it to options
this time and well actually make the cam
is bigger so let's make it like 130 that
should be perfect and yes it is so
options button now let's again ctrl
shift s make sure you don't control us
because I don't wanna override our other
one and again we'll just call this one
options off
and while we're doing all of our off
buttons I kind of have to yeah now we'll
just we'll change the color to whatever
call this was a B a B a B so EB EB EB
ctrl shift s options on actually did we
save do we save our options off in here
pretty sure we didn't as a banjee
options on we didn't say about play on
either
that's a PNG so this is fun there's
gonna be the longest tutorial yet guys
so enjoy it a hump and let's open recent
options off and we will say that as a
PNG safe alright go back to help help is
actually closer to the canvas size of
play
it'll probably exactly the same canvas
size and cells exit so we'll just deal
with this now so help button this is the
help on button it's also control shift s
and say that as a PNG you know all the
directory and then we'll do the exact
same thing for let's over now play off
button I know we can't because we want
the V location to be exactly the same so
let's make this color 61 once we've won
6-1 as it was before does the same color
is this oops that yes it is ctrl shift s
and off ctrl shift s again ctrl shift s
by the way is the same thing as going a
file save as so here it is shift ctrl s
help off what else is there exit so as a
button
all right so ctrl shift s and and let's
say here exit off and exit on as well
well actually weird let's control shift
s right now and save it as a PNG that's
an exit off and this is the on button as
well so we'll change the color to a BBB
shift s exit on we've already saved that
and s once again and finally PNG all
right now go a bunch of buttons right
here yeah we can play around with right
and that's pretty cool and one more
thing I'll do actually is I'll go open
Chrome or any other web browser you guys
might have I'll wait for that to load up
and I will go to come on I'll go to
images and I'll just type in like arrow
or something and I'm just gonna because
I'm trying to did like the Skyrim thing
thing right where it's some got this
like arrow I've said I want to take
exactly the same one but um there's
anything remotely similar this one's not
bad oh that's perfect and this is
actually an SVG a file so let's just
it's not yourself let's just hit the
prints friend button and we'll hit up
paint with paint
and we will control-v that and we only
want this portion so let's take roughly
push an arrow control C control n don't
save and we'll paste that in and we will
just delete this past that we don't need
hope you should done this Photoshop
actually might have been easier actually
now this'll do okay cool be there's no
shock offer to me and stuff
all right control it and again and there
we go so go to perfect our now well
that's um we have to put that into
Photoshop anyway let's go documents and
Eclipse workspace to mine front it's
also textures and no no Tasha's menu a
ridge and we'll just say this is arrow
top Andrea let's go out of this and
let's go to Photoshop file open and we
will open our arrow and all I'm gonna do
is I wanna get the paint bucket and
first of all actually I'll get the magic
wand which is right here I'll double
click on background to make it an
editable layer I'll click that and I had
to let so we've lost our white
background I'll grab the paint bucket
and I'm gonna make this a slightly grey
color and just drop it on that simple as
that
alright maybe a bit brighter make sure
into the background and one more thing
I'll actually do is ctrl T and I'll
rotate it hit shift so it aligns and
I'll rotate it 90 degrees to the left
and then we have this wonderful thing so
first thing is it's huge that is the
first unfortunate thing about this
awesome arrow it's massive
we obviously don't want an arrow that
big we want an arrow roughly because our
other stuff was 30 pixels big so let's
make this about 20 pixels big 20 pixels
high and maybe like 22 wide proceed a
lot of clipping will occur and now let's
down scale this arrow whoops and this
one look pretty if we are if we put
it here but that's alright it'll look
good in our game trust me
so that should be good
all right actually no that's not very
good so Matt again try again I don't
know the controls that would go all the
way back here by the way so my apologies
I just want to make sure that it's as
big as it can be without actually going
over so hit enter it'll go back to its
anti aliased
form we can move it now you zoom out
through 100% you can see that it looks
normal like animal hour so now let's
control just control shift s and we'll
save it as peridot PNG over here okay so
now we've got everything we need to
actually make this work now so let's so
let's get started okay so what we want
to do right now is go into launcher and
in our render menu what I want to do is
after we fill we've filled the rectangle
background right and after we've
actually drawn the image let's try and
draw the image we've already got a try
and cash method which is pretty good
let's try and cash thing not really a
method let's draw another image Jade
I'll draw image and this time we'll go
image IO dot read and we'll go display
dock which probably changed this just
for their sake to launch it or class
launcher dock class don't get resource
and we'll get a menu full touch menu
full slash button oh no it's not it's
play off and again we'll put that at
about seven again I did this on the live
stream so I'm pretty sure number six
ninety I think it was six ninety was how
good my memory is six ninety and one
thirty
I think all experiment this and
obviously the height and width is with
this thirty I mean the width is eighty
the height is 30 and that's what we need
I'm serving now
all right but we only want to do that
cause everyone do the other thing their
work the other way around if our input
hand law dot Mouse X so the the mouse
the position with the mouse on the
screen is greater than 690 right so okay
what I'm saying here is that if if we're
if if we're greater than 690 so in other
words if we're past this and we're input
handler dot Mouse X is less than 100
sorry no hundred thirty six six ninety
plus Eddy I could work that out and say
that is seven hundred and seventy but it
could just let the computer do it
because it's much easier right if you do
if you do it like that so if it's weed
within the plaything and it's also input
handler dot Mouse Y is greater than 130
and less than 160 or in other words
input and handle up Mouse Y is less than
130 plus 30 because 30 is the height
then let's not draw that that'll be our
else but otherwise let's draw let's draw
our on button okay all right so I hope
you guys understand that basically what
we're saying is that if we put our mouse
over the play button let's draw this
let's draw the on button and if the
mouse isn't on top of the play button
then let's roll the off one so let's hit
that and see that works it didn't
because we've got an illegal argument
exception what is that what is our legal
argument
huh okay first of all we didn't put dot
PNG alright cool so we're gonna play
button and when we put the mouse over it
check that out it changes right just
like that so that is pretty cool let's
get rid of this play button thing so
let's get rid of G dot drawstring and
let's not set any of this stuff cool now
let's copy and paste this code and do
exactly the same thing for the let's see
what else we have the options button the
play button and the exit button alright
so let's set these first the options
button obviously takes up
I guess less of a the options button is
has a greater width because if we go
into here you can see the options button
is wider than the play button so keeping
that in mind we should push it back a
bit so 6:41 and like too high it will
make it the y-value 170 from the top and
again it was 130 by 30 so let's last
that up and obviously change this to the
options button and let's also do the and
when it changes as well so if in other
words if we're that and that plus the
width which is 130 and we're less then
what is it and we're sorry i am i
greater than the Y which is 170 170 plus
30 then yeah cool what else is that
there's a Help button
and there's the exit button and we're
over now we're an hour in two minutes
yay I don't know I might have
fast-forward at the bar before so you
guys don't know that but I yeah all
right so let's
okay so 690 that's probably fine
actually
yep all right so 690 and plus 80 a week
yeah it was still a deal right yeah this
is still 80 cool oh this should be fine
actually plus 80 and but the wine is
changed to what is it like 210 I think
that were 210 and again this should be
210 be 210 and then our last one should
be 250 if we continue in the same
fashion that should be 250
that should be 210 good thing the x
value doesn't change let's hit this and
see if it worked
options didn't work options didn't
really work but otherwise we seem to be
working so I look at me looking up the X
button I even though we haven't
implemented it yet
all right we haven't actually met at
work yet um so the problem is that we
didn't still 130 cool awesome so we've
got now we've got a complete set of
workable buttons that light up let's do
the arrow now and the error is pretty
simple so if our mouse is over the
button then let's draw image image IR
publish to copy and paste it launch it
up class don't get resource and where
are we and I think it's just menu
peridot pantry and what we're going to
do is we want to draw that
well let's just draw it it like it's 130
pixels just 90 plus like 80 134 22 but
twenties the size of it no I'll say that
what I said
I was that perfect
no I'm kidding I worked out those chords
on the live stream I'm not that I'm not
that good um all right so let's copy and
paste this for everything else and we
should be working except obviously we
need to adjust the y-values of all of
this
so basically it's offset by four pixels
from the tops or this is 210 so
therefore it's 214 and it's 250 so
therefore is 254 all right check that
out we've got a working button thing
with menus so now the I want to wrap up
this tutorial by simply explaining to
you guys how to do the exit button
because for the play I haven't decided
yet if I want to have it or on a
different thread if I drew it in this
lot of code and I'm not gonna go over
that now but the point is I'll show you
guys how to actually make but make these
buttons do something so that so that
you'll be able to you know
customize them a bit so exit button
let's go down to exit button so if our
mouse is over the exit button it's on
top of the exit button and so make sure
you put another this this if statement
inside the if statement for the exit
button alright make sure you do that
don't put it outside because we only
want to be able to say that if our mouse
is on top of the exit button and we
click then yeah in other words you could
do it outside but what you would have to
do is you would have to say that and
then you will have to add in an and
clicked type thing all right but we
don't have to we just go if our input
handler dot mouse button
equals 1 which is our left mouse button
0 equals nothing zero means that is not
selected then let's system dot exit with
a set of 0 right so if our mouse is on
top of the exit button and we click then
close a game look that it works and just
for this sake let's just copy and paste
this into everything and maybe change
this to like system dot out dot print
line play and we'll copy this and paste
it here and say options and here we'll
paste it and say help
so they forgot to console and you can
see if we click places play few times
and
ah
oK we've got no mouse released statement
apparently so if I hit play and then I
move my mouse down it closes the game
alright so we want to have a mouse
released we want to say that mouse
button equals zero
if we release else I don't know sure why
didn't do that before how'd you know it
work actually I can say the problem the
problem is that we've actually got a
mouse button either gaben in clicked not
impressed get it I'm not impressed
because it's not in pressed haha um so
now if we click you can see that it
actually does work yay so if we hit play
if we had exit it will hopefully exit as
you can see and play let's just get rid
of its spanking out game run pretty slow
because it's printing this out every
many times a second if we hit play
it says play options help and exit so
there we go
simple as that we've got our working
buttons so yeah that was the longest
tutorial ever and so I hope you enjoyed
it and I will see you guys next week
where we will make the play button play
will make it a little option screen and
in general we'll finish up our launches
so yeah see you guys later
and make sure you like the video if you
liked it because I spent over now doing
this so umm yeah and I'll see you guys
next week bye